[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
will you do a weekend with me 100 are
you kidding me and you'll answer the
phone like you'll answer it I'll promote
I want people to get the full Bobby Lee
experience
so great how many seats is it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the best version of who I am right
oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today is Monday October 17th and Bobby
Lee was on the road with Tom Segura all
weekend long opening up his shows in big
venues all across Canada welcome back to
the joke World comedy update every
single Monday bringing you the comedy
news that you need to know from your
favorite comedians your favorite podcast
anything and everything literally
anything and everything to do with
comedy all in one place one YouTube
channel making it easy for you so please
remember to subscribe to joke world
right now go follow us on Instagram if
you want some free stickers sent to you
in the mail and download this episode on
Spotify if you feel like supporting the
show
can I ask you a favor yeah will you do a
weekend with me I would love to were you
for real 100 are you kidding me and
you'll answer the phone like you'll
answer promote we first heard about the
possibility of these two doing dates
together a few months ago back when
Bobby Lee was on your mom's house in
August but at the time when they were
talking about on the podcast it just
seemed like another pipe dream how many
times have you heard Bobby Lee say
something on a podcast make these big
plans that never actually end up
happening but this time they came
through but you know Bert offered me a
bunch of stuff okay and he never did it
what do you mean I don't know I'm gonna
make this happen to make this happen and
it just I never I called my agents and
they go he never called so what I'm
saying to you is is that
um is this something that's coming out
of your butthole hold on or is it real
I'm texting my tour manager right now
wow it's pretty sick actually that they
were able to plan this for the exact
dates that they said on the podcast
right in front of all of us and then
follow through with it I'm curious to
see if anyone that saw that podcast went
out and bought tickets and were able to
make it to that show or if they were
already sold out or if anyone watching
this video right now was at any of these
shows that Bobby Lee was opening for Tom
Segura I'd be very curious to hear from
you hear how the actual show was inside
the building oh I got a response from
who from who Taylor tour manager okay
what did they say okay
so the first like
like good Stringer dates yeah would be
in October
I know that's a little difficult it is
difficult but let's see
it would be
a a Canada run
I love Canada we would do Kitchener
London are they outdoor events no no
these are all okay I'll do it indoor
yeah and what are the dates
uh October 13th through the 16th even
though in the grand scheme of things
this is definitely just another random
weekend for these two huge comedians
that tour all the time you could tell
they were definitely more excited about
this one than just a normal show just
based on what they shared on social
media way more pictures and videos than
normal them hanging out backstage before
the show during the show taking videos
of each other they seemed excited
seemingly having a very fun time
together so hopefully this starts a
similar trend of two big comedians just
pairing up on random weekends going out
on tour and giving the fans that
Ultimate Experience you know I would
deal for two grand and everyone heard it
first and I would do 20 minutes yeah and
it'd be a good time for me to kind of
try new stuff too as well no uh no no
no no what do you mean it means you
swing the [ __ ] hammer on these shows
you don't try new stuff yeah these are
Big venues like he's really successful I
want people to get the full Bobby Lee
experience I'll kill and no [ __ ]
Asian [ __ ] just go out there no just uh
yeah yeah it'll be fun skank Fest 2022
kicked off last week in Las Vegas
usually the legendary Comedy Festival is
held in New York City but this year the
legionist gangs headed to Sin City and
took about every comedian in the world
with them literally the list of
comedians is too long to read obviously
the core group of guys like Luis Gomez
Big Jay oakerson art shaffir it's mostly
New York guys but look at this list it's
insane Mark Norman Dave Attell Nick
Mullen Shane Gillis Tony Hinchcliffe Tim
Dillon it's literally everybody except
for Tom and Bobby because they were in
Canada there's no way the FBI is not
watching this Festival there are feds in
every Harley Quinn looking door in this
room is a fact test people you're
hanging out with you know you real ass
dude and they go what [ __ ] I still have
never been but skank Fest 100 seems like
the best time in the world for sure the
best Comedy Festival ever now that it's
officially complete we're gonna make a
more in-depth video about this year's
gang Fest coming out sometime this week
so damn if you were there good for you
hit me up on Instagram I want to hear
about it get some details hear about
your experience if you went to skating
Fest this year DM me on Instagram let's
talk YouTube did take down two bears one
cave today uh pretty quickly uh it was
flagged and we've been in contact with a
number of people over there
um trying to get it resolved trying to
get it back up
um right now we're still waiting and I
think it's going to be a few more hours
before we know but we'll either get it
back up or we'll have another solution
and we will update you as soon as we
know
thanks the most recent episode of two
bears one cave that was uploaded this
morning has been pulled down by YouTube
I feel like we can assume it was a very
funny episode if YouTube is going out of
its way to censor it hey guys we just
got a great episode
it's your author but my buddy Tommy he
really pulled all the weight today
it was great and we really hope you
liked subscribe tune in and check out
every Wednesday Monday
[Music]
Tom sent out a few tweets this morning
saying that they are working on getting
the video re-uploaded as soon as
possible then he had a few Instagram
videos today just keeping us posted
along the way of what's happening with
the episode by the time you're watching
this video I would almost guarantee that
it's re-uploaded YouTube they had to
figure it out by now or they figure out
some other solution but yeah pretty
annoying of YouTube to just deem what is
appropriate for us to hear what jokes
that we can handle thanks for keeping us
safe YouTube
I bet it's a great episode I wonder what
got him censored I think Tom was talking
about Ayahuasca or something I don't
know maybe this video is going to get
pulled down because we're talking about
that episode two bears one cave who
knows I bet it's back up by now though
guest spots from last week your mom's
house did not have a guest two bears one
cave was Burton Tom Tom and Bert if that
video is re-uploaded by YouTube whiskey
Ginger had on Frankie Quinones flagrant
talked with Danny Brown kill Tony
tonight is the crew from Austin Hans Kim
William Montgomery and David Lucas
should be a ripper of an episode and
Mark Norman was on Stevo's Wild Ride the
uh Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee like
uh that
is insanely that that would move the
needle if you yeah that would help well
there's like eight of them and they're
all on Netflix like during the pandemic
prime time oh I watched it all I love
that show Michael Richards one is great
oh shoot they uh addressed the n-word
stuff really yeah I mean you would kind
of have to yeah I feel like they did it
on Curb Your Enthusiasm while one of the
seasons that's right I brought him off
for the Remake and they're like uh they
kind of made a joke about it right I
mean you would have to you couldn't I
mean like if we had Michael Richards on
the podcast he couldn't like dance
around that no that's a big big n-word
in the room
but that's the weird thing about cancel
or whatever you want to call it is
Michael ridges did that I don't know
what was that 10 years ago it was 2006.
okay wow it was it was actually pretty
[ __ ] rare for there to be a video
camera yeah on a cell phone right right
that's what got him I think that that
the size of that file was in the
kilobytes uh yeah well it killed a bit
his career
the latest this past weekend episode
with Theo Von is still Scott stepp the
honeydews latest episode is still John
fidelberg from Barstool tigerbelly did
not have a guest last week The Joe Rogan
Experience talked with comedian Eliza
Schlesinger and we might be drunk out on
Phil Hanley stand-up specials have come
out recently or at least like come out
this month-ish uh Dane Cook above it all
is available on momenthhouse.com and
according to the description join Dane
Cook on October 5th for his latest
stand-up comedy event above it all
filmed from his front porch overlooking
Los Angeles you also have Hassan Minaj
the king's dresser on Netflix and of
course Robert Kelly killbox is out now
as well on Louis ck.com that does it for
this week's comedy update be sure to
come back next Monday for some more
comedy news and in the meantime you know
please subscribe to joke world this
channel right here if you're interested
in comedy if you love comedy then you
will not regret subscribing to this
channel we cover everything happening
from your favorite comedians current
events old highlights from stuff it's a
funny channel it's a good channel to
subscribe to
if you subscribe tell them tell them in
the comments it's a good channel to
subscribe to my life's never been better
say some stuff like that then also if
you want some more comedy content you
can follow us on Instagram WE Post
similar things but no pressure and I
know I'm being really needy right now
I've already asked you to do two things
so far subscribe to this channel follow
us on Instagram if there's a third thing
that you wanted to do if you're not
planning on doing thing after this if
you're gonna not watch another video
after this anyway then you know you
could go to Spotify or apple or wherever
you listen to podcasts and
download this episode that'd be funny
that'd be that'd be weird and funny
download it see what happens
[Music]